que l'on mène sur le terrain.
Jacaudrey Charbonneau est allé
rencontrer quelques-uns des
candidats.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Laval, ça a un petit peu
la réputation de la petite ville
en dehors de Montréal,
mais ce n'est plus ça!
- On la qualifie encore parfois
de ville-dortoir, la troisième
ville en importance au Québec.
L'enjeu à Laval, ce serait quoi
la question de l'urne pour vous?
- C'est une bonne question!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Avez-vous fait votre choix ?
- Pas encore, je sais même pas
qui est-ce qui se présente.
- Je m'occupe pas
bien, bien de ça.
- Les élections municipales
semblent pourtant susciter
peu d'intérêt, malgré
les huit candidats qui
se présentent à la mairie.
- Les gens, en très forte
majorité, nous disent :
"Ça va bien, je suis satisfait."
- Les finances publiques
sont en ordre, la croissance
est au rendez-vous,
et c'est sur ce bilan
que le candidat du Mouvement
lavallois fait campagne.
STÉPHANE BOYER, candidat mairie
Laval, chef, Mouvement lavallois
- On a créé des belles
fondations. Maintenant,
il faut construire le reste
de la maison et, donc, c'est
de ne pas perdre ce bel élan-là.
- La coupure avec la corruption
de l'ère Vaillancourt est aussi
effectuée; le dauphin du maire
sortant, Marc Demers, mise
d'ailleurs aussi sur ce legs.
MARC DEMERS,
maire sortant de Laval
- Le fait de ne plus être
dans les journaux pour des
mauvaises raisons, la façon
systématique que nous l'étions,
Laval n'a jamais eu autant
de subventions des autres
paliers de gouvernement
que présentement.
- Je me présente, ça fait
quatre ans que je suis
le chef de l'opposition.
- Mais la vision du candidat
Michel Trottier est tout autre.
MICHEL TROTTIER, candidat mairie
de Laval, chef, Parti Laval
- Comme il ne s'est rien créé
à Laval depuis huit ans,
je suis pas surpris, moi,
qu'on parle pas de Laval.
- Un leadership fort,
de meilleurs services
de proximité; il y a
beaucoup à faire, selon lui.
- Ça aboutit pas actuellement,
les grands projets à Laval :
biométhanisation, complexe
aquatique, centre animalier;
c'est tous des projets
qui sont tombés à l'eau,
qui se sont pas réalisés.
- Il faut pas se tromper
avec M. Trottier.
- Non, non, non, non!
(rires)
- Même nom de famille, mais
la bannière est bien différente.
- On se ressemble pas,
on a un prénom différent.
On travaille pas
de la même façon!
(rires)
- Sophie Trottier est à
la tête du parti Action Laval,
qui a récupéré des conseillers
qui ont claqué la porte du parti
du maire Demers en 2018.
SOPHIE TROTTIER, cand. mairie
de Laval, cheffe, Action Laval
- L'enjeu, moi, j'espère que
les gens vont retomber en amour
avec la politique et recommencer
à y croire, parce que ce qu'on
entend depuis les dernières
années, bien, premièrement,
les gens sont surtaxés,
moi la première, et les gens ne
comprenaient pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils augmentent toujours
nos taxes, alors qu'on voit pas
grand-chose qui est livré.
- Les budgets, la gouvernance...
- Michel Poissant faisait
aussi partie des dissidents
du Mouvement lavallois;
lui aussi critique la gestion
de l'administration actuelle,
devenue trop bureaucratique.
MICHEL POISSANT, candidat mairie
de Laval, chef, Laval Citoyens
- Vaillancourt nous a peut-être
volés, mais nos services de
proximité étaient au rendez-vous
et les taxes augmentaient pas.
Ça, c'est le sentiment des gens
que ça fait longtemps
qu'ils sont à Laval.
- Il a fondé son parti
pour briguer la mairie.
Sa promesse phare :
l'aménagement d'un sentier
linéaire de 8 km.
- La pandémie nous a rappelé
que l'accès à la nature
est une donnée fondamentale.
Les Lavallois nous rappellent,
avec les tours à condo
qui poussent partout,
qu'ils en ont suffisamment.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Selon moi, l'environnement
reste l'enjeu du 21e siècle.
On souhaite la création
d'un grand parc sur
la rivière des Mille Îles.
- Au conseil, on va faire
une demande pour que
la Ville se dote d'un droit de
préemption. S'il y a un terrain
de golf qui va être vendu,
bien, que la Ville puisse avoir
le premier choix et de l'acheter
au prix du marché, évidemment.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On va financer entre 50 % et
70 % 'une passe d'autobus pour
un jeune qui est aux études.
- Les promesses
environnementales prennent
de plus en plus de place dans
la campagne à Laval, et c'est
justement l'objectif du candidat
indépendant Nicolas Lemire.
À 25 ans, il se présente pour
la deuxième fois à la mairie.
Connu pour son blogue qui
s'intitule "Pas le maire
de Laval", il a publié
un manifeste de 48 propositions
pour la transition écologique.
NICOLAS LEMIRE, candidat
indépendant à la mairie de Laval
- J'ai commencé par envoyer
ce manifeste-là à tous
les partis politiques et je leur
ai demandé de s'approprier
les idées qui sont dedans.
Moi, je veux que ça se réalise.
Moi, je veux que sur
les bulletins de votes
des Lavallois, il y ait
le plus d'options progressistes
et écologiques possible.
- Une façon d'influencer
les idées, croit-il, de contrer
le manque d'intérêt des citoyens
pour la politique municipale.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Laval.